toxic smog hangs over Tehran schools and
kindergartens have been closed for a
week children and people with
respiratory problems have been told to
stay indoors the her on sits at a high
altitude and is surrounded by a mountain
range which can trap polluted air the
government says it's investing millions
of dollars to reduce pollution but many
here believe it's the quality of fuel in
vehicles that's causing the problem the
government insists it's not it is this
court in La Jolla
ok the Environment Department earlier
said that gasoline share in an air
pollution is minimum the fuels type is
not the issue the pollution created for
example by non-standard motorcycles as
I'm told the pollution by a motorcycle
is equivalent to 7 vehicles and we have
many non-standard motorcycles but on the
streets of the city many are not
convinced the government should be kind
to us and improve the quality of our
fuel then we can breathe more easily you
don't feel like you're breathing and
oxygen at all if it's not fuel then what
is it maybe there are natural factors
such as inversion but the major reason
is the lead in our gasoline air
pollution is the daily story of children
in Tehran every night they are waiting
to hear that schools are closed tomorrow
this pollution is very serious look at
people they're wearing a mask and can't
breathe they'll talk pollution is also
taking its toll on the health service
with more people being treated in
hospital for breathing problems
more than 60% of cars on the streets are
old ones 20 years or more they should be
replaced with new models these old cars
are even worse than the new low-quality
types produced by domestic automakers if
we can replace these worn-out old cars
with hybrid or electronic cars we can
get rid of this pollution if we were not
under sanctions we could easily import
high quality spare parts and get rid of
this situation many in Tehran say they
have no choice but to live under this
gray cloud at this time of year you
should be able to see the snow-capped
mountains that surround Tehran but there
behind that layer of smog Iranians are
not only concerned about the health
implications of the pollution but also
that is robbing them of their idyllic
skyline Assad Begg al jazeera Tehran